thank you for talking to me about this
because it was one of those movies that
i had to pay attention to because i had
no idea what was going to happen
i very much appreciate that how much how
nice is that actually yeah no i love
that i don't know what's gonna happen at
the end
yeah and with this like i i feel like it
was still very unexpected there were way
more people that ended up dead than i
thought would so
that was uh definitely unexpected
and i'm curious i mean when you guys
read this script what was it that
interested you are you like is this the
kind of book you would normally read
like what was it about the story that
you liked
i think we did you know being a huge fan
of like
this like movies like this from the 70s
and like the thriller aspect and this
genre was like really exciting and the
director's vision of it um was it was so
clear
um but i i i really love that
there is the thriller aspect which is
you know being in a
in in the middle of a tsunami
um but within that you have the dynamic
of
two people who um
are really flawed
and
um and really have to
learn especially for my character
um somebody who has
uh lives a lot with a lot of fear and
anxiety and trusts no one besides
herself um and as a single mother
knowing that she's got to put her child
above everything else and really is you
know
can't trust her their life in anyone
else's hands but in the middle of a
tsunami
what they they find themselves in
parker shay's character um
you know she's really
learning to take down pieces of armor to
be able to accept his his help and his
um and his loyalty which is um
i just love that whole dynamic within
the a thriller concept
and shay agrees
yeah i i mean
yeah i'm a huge fan of the 70s i'm a
huge you know easy writer raging bulls i
i love it and i i i read this tonight
i kind of thought you know i always read
and say do i do can i figure out what to
do with this this this guy you know and
um
and then
you know my relationship to every
character in it when olivia signed on
i wanted to see her do something else
and go in there i knew she was ready and
bruce earned he's a legend he's tonight
same thing with frank willow and so i it
came together and these things sometimes
they work sometimes they don't you know
what i mean but you always want to have
an experience and even if they
don't work i want an experience and this
one didn't disappoint and i i think you
feel that with this i think it's a
thriller i think it's a great ride but
you care about the characters and that's
that's kind of a lost art now you know
storytelling and characters you care
about you know what i mean
you still get a car crash you still get
guns or you still get you know blow you
know drugs and stuff but it's it's
surrounded by watching these characters
try to get out of those
situations
yeah one of the things i found so
interesting about it is that these
characters on the surface feel like that
familiar type of character in this type
of story but they're much more complex
and nuanced than that were those layers
always there were those things that
were added did it get developed from the
first time you read the script to when
you shot it or were those layers always
a part of it
i i think um there's a good part of the
the dynamic that was in the script
already but
just like any role you bring your own
history your own
um sensibilities your own
feelings and
um it was really i feel you know you do
your own work before you get to set but
when shay and i
were able to get into a room together
and we went through every single line in
the script not just our scenes but
everything to get a real sense of like
how we wanted our piece of the the pie
to fit into the to the world you know
that's when it starts to get really
layered and then our connection you know
like we
you know you do movies and of course you
know you have to show up and you have
that dynamic and hopefully everyone can
deliver on set but like shay and i were
really lucky that we
really just bonded as individuals um
outside and so
that was that helps to bring in those
layers once you're on
on camera so i think you know
it's it's like maybe 40 and then the
other 60 is what happens once you're
there and what you bring and what your
connection is
going to step on her just a little bit
and give her
she's you know
these things are not easy they're never
easy
they're never easy
and you come in and they demand a lot of
you and and we
you know she went in and just
she was she she went deep and and and
did something i haven't seen her do in
this piece and i'm i was really blown
away by it and um and and bruce would
say the same thing and so it was it was
really gratifying yeah this this piece
thanks shay what was it like to work
with bruce darren is he what is he like
on set is he someone who shares a lot of
stories or is it just all about the work
for him
it's both
it's both he has he has lived a thousand
lives and he remembers every single one
of them
and then you've got shay
who
is enthralled by every single part of
movie making and our business and knows
the history of everything so then
there's someone like me that gets to
watch you know shay would come in every
time we had a break he'd ask about some
other movie or some other thing or this
act or this and so you know there's a
lot of stuff that i didn't know but i
was able to learn through shay's
questioning of bruce so and bruce has so
many stories
and on top of that you know he's you
know 80 and shows up every day
like is so invested in the work care so
much about it wants to talk about it
wants to get into it um
and
um he's everything that you would want
someone
like bruce stern to be
here here i can't you know it's
the story's right you know you can't it
it went from just incredible stories
about nicholson
and king of marvin gardens to
watching him
tell olivia why a banana and mayonnaise
sandwich was
is the greatest
thing and he eats them every day
and you know what i mean so it was
obtuse and beautiful
and crass and just everything that you
know that and it was i mean this is why
we're here talking about it you know
what i mean
well let me know for you i mean your
character has this relationship that has
a very heightened level of intensity to
it
and you have a scene in this that gets
pretty physical with him what were those
conversations like did you have
discussions about how to handle that and
what sort of planning and staging you
wanted to do for that
yeah we you know it's an independent
movie first of all so
you know our budget is you know we don't
have like a whole team of people like
normally like what what shay's probably
dealing with on mission impossible
vastly different
but
you know these moments really matter
like they have to be crazy they got wild
that night no that's what i mean like
but so that's the thing is that we don't
have that team
so then we all as actors we have to like
we go we have to do up 200 percent
on that because there aren't we have to
think like it's really and really
instead of it in in a way i think
um instead of anything being like truly
like choreographed like with stunned
people it just became so visceral and
emotional and it got really wild like
shea was saying because you know it's a
black belt in corrupt and taekwondo yeah
so i knew how to handle myself um but
it everything needed to get really
it just we were able to just as actors
go like
like what what do we want this to be and
it really was all motivated by
what would really happen what are those
what are those emotions and just we
basically that's all we did was talk
about it
and then
like go to town you know there were
people there like coming in and saying
okay there's this and this is gonna
happen i mean we had like some people on
set for like security reasons and
insurance reasons and things you need
but like
the truth of it is that like we as
actors just sat down and said like
you know make sure that it's safe but
like we all shake hands on go to town go
to okay we all we are gonna we're gonna
do this okay
and you know there was times we were
like you know i'm like okay like that
you know she's like got you know you
know something happens to his back
something's happening to my throat
something's happening in my arm you know
but but i don't know it's i don't know
how weird we are but like it kind of
feels good like you know like sometimes
the bruise can kind of feel good you
kind of like push on a bruise like i
think when we had those you're kind of
like yeah we did something we just
you know and there was a it's really fun
to be able to
like
to trust each other to go as far as we
need to go
that's that's the whole key when i'm in
doing these heavy fight scenes and she
did one of the biggest one thing
on the on the on the film
if there's trust and love involved
you can go at someone really hard
you know what i mean if if it's not
there then you don't but if it's there
she she was like bring it let's just
let's let's bring it you know
and you feel that you feel that on it's
i was i was very
very taken you know with her work on it
yeah as a dancer i can appreciate
wearing bruises as pride when you do
something like that i i have definitely
been there but also then you get it too
like there the physicality is really
nothing unless you have the emotion
and i mean
i i'm pretty sure i don't know if this
is even allowed but they they you know
like the anybody that i had to hit or
slap those are there was nothing fake
about it
it was like it was all like when i'm
getting choked out i'm getting choked
out like when i'm getting thrown here we
we just kind of we didn't the thing is
when you're on an indie movie you don't
have the luxury of time to figure it all
out we all just like shay was saying
there's love and trust and so we go
we're all here to make this as
believable as possible so
you know what is the limit that you can
take and we all talked about our limits
and yes that we all had pretty far
limits like you can do x y and z to me
and
and um and that's what you saw so
everything you see is what really
happened
well what's what's next for you guys
shay are you gonna be returning for
season two of perry mason and olivia are
you gonna be involved with this new g4
at all like what what's going on with
you guys i would love to be the new
perry mason as well
i would love one of my good friends
chris chalk from the newsroom on there
that show is perry mason's just so good
he's gorgeous too
i would love for shay to do a little bit
more work on my end to get me into all
of his projects
he's on mission impossible right now
he's coming back to l.a i'm like i feel
like i'm his publicist now i'm like then
he's going to come back he's doing
another big movie
yeah um oh i
yeah yeah knockwood knockwood
yeah
um
she's got a lot going on she's being
very humble too so
no i'm just being jealous of shay's
career
humble i'm just pissed off
i'm wearing matt why isn't your agent on
my team
she knows how to make me laugh
you laughing but i'm serious shay
he keeps laughing he keeps thinking i'm
joking this whole time all
day he thinks i'm laughing like tell
your brother jack wiggum
who's that caa so am i it's his agent
but i'm his client this is not a bit jay
um all right all right
see there it is on collider has it you
said all right listen we're we're
we do no but seriously to get back we're
this these kind of films need need need
people like you to get out there and and
we we love the film we i mean we
i'm i'm running on no sleep in london uh
shooting mission
she's saving animals doing real work you
know what i mean
we're here you know
because we love it we love the peace we
love the experience of it we love you
know so
um and i don't do much publicity at all
and this one i i really feel strongly
about so we're very appreciative
yeah and i mean you guys are all
excellent in this and it's it's so great
to watch great actors but watching great
actors together is even more fun so i
think that especially with something
like this just watching because you can
tell it makes such a difference with
your performances too
thanks it means a lot
like bruce you know
some of that stuff that he and i and
then at the end with her and
it's it's it's unbelievable watching him
to continue to dig dig out great
performances you know
and i also really love olivia the music
video you did for imagine dragons i mean
oh yeah it must be so fun to do
something like that where you don't have
to worry about dialogue and you can just
do like some crazy stuff
yeah that was fun that was my first
thing back from the pandemic my first
job was like to go and
and
and i love the imagine dragons and
they're such an amazing band and um and
they're such good people all of them
and then um and the the director was
really collaborative with me and the
band and i said i want to bring my my
good friend adrian martinez um on to
to play with us and um and that was just
that was
that was a lot of fun for sure and you
asked about g4 and i want to just say
like i'm super excited about the network
coming back
and i have told them that i am here and
you know super excited to do whatever
they need to help out in any way
does that feel kind of like a strange
full circle thing that that's coming
back into your life in some way yeah
truly i feel like it has never left my
life i miss attack of the show
every single day every single day like
i'm i i miss that time in my life i
missed that show
it was so much fun um
i miss everything about it there it
literally isn't a day that goes by that
i'm like oh like in somewhere in the
back of my head i'm just like i just i
miss it so
um it hasn't i don't i don't feel it
it's never really left me
i'm excited that it's getting another
shot to come back around and
um and be there for the people who who
watched it for so long before and also
to bring on new new audiences and fans
as well so
you know i'm here whenever they need me
they just need a call
well thanks you guys for talking to me
it was great to watch you both in this
and hopefully shave the mission
impossible movies will finish filming
sunday
so that we can see them
thank you
they're going to be mission impossible
like webisodes you just have to put out
little by little by little
it's pretty good i'll tell you that it's
such a wild production it feels like
it's been filming for a decade so it's
gonna be so good i mean uh
these guys are so smart
thank you both
all right thank you so much